>> Hello everyone,
welcome to this candidate
talk by Cameron Musco.
So Cameron is currently
our graduate student from
MIT supervised by Nancy Lynch.
He works on
large scale algorithms
across a number of
fields ranging from
like numerical linear algebra
such as for like
Lanczos's methods for PCA,
search as like low rank
approximation and so on.
And also he has worked on
sublimial algorithms also for
low ranked
approximations and so on.
And he recently also
started to work on
social network algorithms.
He also has interesting
biological computations as so on.
So this talk is
about the power of
simple algorithms from
data science to
biological systems.
>> Alright.
Thanks. Okay so today
I'm going to be
talking about the role
of simple algorithms
in data science.
Specifically I'm
going to talk about
why really simple often
randomized methods like
stochastic gradient ascent in
random hashing
random sampling are
so powerful and so ubiquitous
and data applications.
And I'm going to overview
some of my work in this area.
So specifically I am going to
overview some work
on a new class
of sampling algorithms for
linear algebraic computation.
But let us do some really
powerful and surprising things.
Like for example something
your time Lorenc approximation
of matrices and
some really nice things.
>> Sorry, can you speak
up a little bit louder?
>> Yeah sure. So I'm going
to overview might
work on sort of
investing in
these algorithms and
especially their role in
linear algebraic computation.
And then if I have some time
at the end I'm going to
talk about some connections
with biological
systems and try and
understand when we're studying
really simple
randomized algorithms
really it's all about
figuring out how
small stochastic
interactions can
lead to some sort
of complex behavior.
And then I am going
to talk about how
insights from this can
be used to study beyond
algorithm design but algorithms
that are being
conducted in nature and
specifically some
decision making
algorithms that answer use.
Alright. So we all
know that data science
and machine learning are
huge consumers of
algorithms and we also
know that algorithms
aren't just a nice to have,
first algorithms aren't
just saving us resources.
They can really lead to
breakthroughs in these areas.
The thing that's probably
at the forefront of
a lot of people's minds
for example is the success of
deep learning and neural nets
for image classification.
This has been driven
forward by a lot
of many advances
one of them being
that we can just scale
these networks to
huge data sets and also
just a huge model sizes.
So that's really
a computational breakthrough
that's driving
a learning breakthrough.
In ergonomics
the same things happening.
Basically we can do
genetic sequencing way
faster than we
could do before and
this is a computational
breakthrough.
Basically we're able
to take a bunch of
short reads of DNA and
stitch them together
massively in parallel and
therefore generate more data for
ourselves and actually generate
the ability to get
insights from this data.
So these are just some examples.
Another one is like
are in remote sensing
the ability to do
real time hazard monitoring.
This has been driven by
computational advances.
So, cognition advances
matter not just for saving
resources but really to
drive breakthroughs and
learning and science.
So what do we need
from algorithms?
We want to design
algorithms that help push
these advances and actually
like push forward
science and learning.
What do we actually need
from these algorithms?
The first thing
is sort of a given
just if you're an
algorithm designer like me,
this is what you're
always looking for.
You want fast rhythms.
And if you are going
to run them on big
data sets you want
things that run say
on linear time and are just
extremely fast and
easy to implement.
But the other things
a little bit less defined.
We somehow want the
algorithms that are
going to actually have
impact on practice or
algorithms that are somehow
flexible and simple.
There are things that
we can adapt to like
a wide range of
application domains.
They work well on lots
of different input types.
They work well when you tweak
the problem that
you're trying to solve,
a little bit or tweak the model
that you're trying to
train a little bit.
And they also work well in
lots of computational
environments.
They're easy to
implement in lots
of computational environments.
So a lot of computational
advances aren't
driven necessarily by algorithm
design but by system design.
We want our algorithms
to fit in with this.
We want things that it's not
hard if there's a whole new,
if there's a new distributed
system that's become
popular it should be easy
to adopt the algorithm
into the system.
It should easy for people to
implement and test and
actually bring up the speed.
So sort of the thesis of
this talking of a lot of
my research is that really
simple randomized methods often
satisfy these criteria
that we're looking
for of being
simultaneously really
fast but also being easy to
implement flexible robust
and all these type of things.
So I'll just give you a couple
of examples of sort of
really common
randomized algorithms
that are used in machine
learning at data science.
Probably the most well-known one
is stochastic gradient ascent.
You start gradient ascent
that is already pretty simple.
I'm trying to
optimize a function in
every step I walk in the
direction of steepest let's say,
and I eventually converge
towards a minimum
or a local minimum.
Stochastic gradient
ascent I just say,
I don't want to compute
a full gradient.
Maybe I just want to
look at one data point
at a time and compute
a gradient based of that.
Some really course estimate of
the gradient which is
correct in expectation.
So I have this
gradient tilde which is
correct in expectation but
might be really far off,
and I might not really
correlate that
strongly as gradient.
I can still take small
enough steps in
these directions and
eventually find that I
convert to a minimum.
This is a hugely
applied algorithm.
Why is it so popular?
One it's applicable
to a really wide range
of problems just like
gradient ascent is.
You can sort of throw it at
any optimization problem.
You have to see what happens.
It's really naturally
distributed.
It's naturally
streaming the steps
that you take are really cheap.
And this is a really
nice thing in practice.
You don't have
these big expensive steps.
You have really cheap many steps
going on at once.
And we also have some
theoretical understanding of it.
At least for convex functions,
we don't understand
exactly why it works for
all functions we apply
it to but by having,
because it's simple enough we
can really do some analysis on
it and try to use
this analysis to
understand what it's doing,
to understand how we like
to modify it and improve it
and things like that.
Another example are a mark
of chain Monte Carlo methods.
It is more like
stochastic gradient ascent
and you can throw them at tons
of problems and
see what happens.
They take really simple steps
and try and sample
from the distribution.
I just need to
say compute ratios
against the distribution
and take relatively
simple steps.
And they're easy to implement.
It's not, if I want
to implement one of
these methods and number
of systems it's easy to do.
And then my final example
which is quite close on
my own researches random hashing
and random feature hashing
and random projection.
Basically this is I have
like a large data set.
For whatever reason I
have many data points
so meaning I have many features.
And I randomly
compress this data
set using some sort
of random hash.
So what I mean is literally I
randomly take
features or I randomly
take examples and
I add them together
maybe with some
appropriate wave function.
Another way of viewing
this is I generate
some random matrix pi from
some distribution and I
compress my matrix with that.
I take A and I multiply it by pi
and apply this random
linear compression.
And I hope that I get
something useful out.
I hope that this
compression a tilde.
I can then use in downstream
applications for things
like clustering or PCA
and things like this.
Again, this method applies
to a huge range of problems.
It's sort of a very generic
pre-processing method
almost like
PCA in a way where
you can apply it,
you can shrink
the size of your data
and then you can
see what happens,
what happens to your results.
It's naturally
distributed is based on
basically just doing
matrix multiplication
which is a super easy thing to
implement and is
widely implemented,
basically implemented in
any system that you're
going to be using.
And again because it's
simple, I mean we have.
It takes some math but we have
good theoretical bounds
for it and we have
some good theoretical
understanding of it.
Based on sort of Johnson
Lindenstrauss type results in
random matrix theory
we can actually sort of
figure out what it's doing and
why it might be working well.
Okay. So also mentioned
that all these
algorithms I mentioned
and other randomized algorithms,
these simple
randomized algorithms
come with other advantages.
They take small
local steps often.
This is certainly true of
stochastic gradient methods.
And this makes them sort of more
tolerant to noise
and perturbations.
For example there's
a lot of work on
stochastic gradients and
asynchronous systems.
And where you basically get
perturbed behavior
because you don't
synchronize the processors
running the steps very well.
And you still see
good behavior in these systems.
So these algorithms can be
perturbed and seemed
to still work well.
They all aggressively trade
approximation for efficiency.
So all the ones that I mentioned
are approximation algorithms.
Randomization and sampling and
sketching naturally lead to
approximation algorithms.
And the good thing
is that often in
data applications there's not
some canonical answer
we're looking for.
We have noise over the data
anyways and by trading off,
by allowing ourselves
some approximation
we can get much more
efficient algorithms.
And then something that
I mentioned while I
was talking about
these is a lot of
these have relatively clean
mathematical analysis
as basically
probabilistic processes.
With random sketching,
yes it's an algorithm
but what you're really
doing is you're saying I
have a random matrix
that I generated.
I applied this to my data set.
What's the effect of this random
when your math on my data set?
And so it's a rather
simple thing to
sort of try to pin down and
figure out what it's doing.
Okay. So this has
been the goal of
a lot of my work
is to basically build out
the toolkit of these
simple in general purpose
randomized methods for
data problems and also
our ability to understand
exactly what they're doing
and to analyze them.
In my work as
[inaudible] mentioned
touches tools in
theoretical computer science,
also in more traditional
numerical computation
and optimization fields.
So, one thing I've
been interested in,
especially interested
in is for example
stochastic gradient methods
which I talked about before.
I've been interested
in understanding how
these methods can be applied
to when you're out the problems.
Canonical problems
and linear algebra
which are useful
for data science.
So one thing I've,
a lot of times we
have bounds for
stochastic gradient methods
for convex problems,
things like solving
linear systems but we don't
necessarily have bounds
for other problems
for not convex problems.
And what I've looked
at is combining
these methods with tools from
numerical linear algebra like
Krylov Subsys methods and using
these to sort of boost
the power of these algorithms,
to try to solve things like
eigenvector approximation,
spectrum approximation,
certain forms of
regular as regression.
To try to expand their use
in linear algebra
and in data science.
And this is required
turning back to
these older tools like
Krylov Subsys methods and
understanding how
do they play with
noise and approximation and
how are they robust
to this noise?
Another piece of my work is
understanding random
sketching methods for
linear algebraic graph problems
and data problems
like clustering in
low rank approximation.
And a dim of my work here has
been trying to understand,
given a random projection method
or a random hashing method,
how do I really characterize?
I'm taking my matrix
and I'm randomly
compressing it and then I'm
going to do an operation on it.
What is the right way to
characterize what
the compression does
to my matrix and how it
approximates the original data?
And then if I can characterize
this in a really
nice clean way then I
can use this to give
applications to lots
of downstream problems.
So this I'm going to
focus on my work there.
And then, a huge amount of
my work has been on sampling,
and sampling is mostly
what I'm going to
talk about today.
Basically, trying to figure
out what is the right way
to sample for linear
algebraic and data problems.
And what I'm going to focus
on today is a line of work,
which focuses specifically on
important sampling methods in
graph-out rhythms and
linear algebraic algorithms,
in sort of a new class
of methods,
which don't fall into the range
of stochastic iterative methods.
They're not quite the
same as random sketching,
although there are
certain similarities,
and they allow us to do
some really powerful things
for canonical problems,
like lowering approximation
or linear system solves.
And then, if I have time,
I'll touch back
on this connection
to biological computation
and some work they've done on
stochastic decision
making in ant colonies
and how we can analyze
this behavior using
a distributed algorithm like
perspective and using a lot of
the same tools we use to
analyze the algorithms
that we ourselves designed.
Let me just briefly overview.
So, as you noticed
in this last slide,
a lot of my work is on
computational linear algebra and
specific computational
linear algebra
focused on data problems.
So, let me just briefly overview
the role of computational
linear algebra in data science
and why I think it's
such an important area
of algorithms to be looking at.
Basically, data is
often represented as
high dimensional
real valued vectors,
and when this is the case,
you can represent
your data set as
a real value matrix with
n rows representing
the data points
and d columns
representing the features.
And then transformations on
this data naturally become
linear algebraic operations.
So things like principle
component analysis,
spectral methods, nonlinear
dimensionality reduction,
kernel methods, linear models,
these things are
all really bread
and butter linear
algebraic operations
that we run daily
on data problems,
and they really come down
to figuring out how to do
basic linear algebraic
computation faster.
The paradigm of working with
data through
matrices and through
linear algebra is so
prevalent that often we
have data that we
can't right quite
represent in this form,
and we actually try
to transform it,
so things like
word embedding and
Word2vec or spectral embeddings
for graphs and
things like DeepWalk.
This is such a
powerful computational
paradigm that we often try to
fit things into
it even when they
don't seem to fit in initially,
and this is because
we have a lot of
really powerful
computational tools
in linear algebra that
we can use to our advantage
for processing data.
In many applications of
linear algebra boiled
down to two core problems.
There's the really
core problems,
like multiplying
matrices together or
multiplying matrices
with vectors, but then,
beyond those are sort of
two really core problems
that at the heart of
a lot of what we do,
and these are
the problems I've sort of
focused on in my research.
One of these is
solving linear systems.
So solving linear systems,
you might think of as applying
the inverse of
a matrix to a vector.
Another way to think
about this is you're just
trying to solve
this minimization problem.
I've given a matrix a I'm
given a target vector b
and I'm trying to find
a vector x that minimizes
the difference
between a, x, and b.
It's like ordinary least
squares regression.
It's used as an
internal loop in things
like iterative
reweighted least squares
for generalized linear models.
It's used inside of
interior point methods,
and also, it's equivalent to
like a projection problem.
The columns of A sort
of define a subspace,
the column span of A.
Ax is some vector
in that subspace,
and what we're looking
for when we solve
this problem is we're
looking for the vector Ax,
the vector in that subspace,
which is closest to
our input vector B.
So, this is a really basic if
you're working in
Euclidean space,
and you're working in sort
of with vectorized data,
this is a really basic operation
that you need to have.
You're figuring out how close
a vector is to a given subspace.
And then, the other
problem that I've
focused a lot on are computing
the top singular vectors
of a matrix or
computing the top
eigenvectors of a matrix.
Basically, you want to find
the singular vectors which
correspond to the largest
singular values in
a matrix or how this
is often viewed at
a high level as
you're trying to find
the directions of
greatest variance in your data.
And the reason you want to do
this is usually you end up,
at some point you
end up projecting
to those dimensions,
those directions.
Basically, you end up
approximating your data set
by just looking at the
directions of greatest variance.
This is the basis behind PCA,
spectral methods, and nonlinear
dimensionality reduction.
One way that I like
to view this problem
is we don't actually care
about finding the direct,
well, sometimes, we do,
but we don't always care
about finding the directions
of largest variance.
We don't actually
care about finding
V1 through VK exactly.
What we often care
about is just that we
capture most of
the variance overall.
So,what we do is we
use these directions to
generate something like
a low rank approximation.
So, specifically, if I let V be
the matrix whose columns are
my top case singular vectors,
those are the directions of
greatest variance in my data.
If I project my matrix to them.
So, I formed this
matrix AVV transpose.
I've drawn this out here,
this is like a thin matrix
AV times a wide
matrix V transpose.
This is the minimum. This is
the rank K matrix which is
closest to my matrix
in a bunch of norms,
for example, the Frobenius
norm where I'm just adding up
the sum of squared entries.
Now, this is really often
times why you want
to use computing
the top casing benefactors
because we find that
in practice a lot of
matrices are close to
low rank or at least they
have decaying spectrums,
and you can approximate
them reasonably
well by a low rank matrices.
And so, this is exactly why
you compute the similar vectors.
You project to them
so that you can
approximate
your matrix as well as
possible with a really concise
low rank representation.
Another way of
thinking about this is
you just find a projection of
your data that preserves
as much structure as possible.
Basically, by hoping
that by getting
a matrix as close as possible
to your original matrix,
you preserve as much
structure as you can.
So that's how I'm going to
think about this problem.
I'm not going to focus on
the singular vectors themselves,
I'm going to focus on
sort of the main reason
we care about
the singular vectors,
which is computing
low rank approximation.
Okay, so how do we
solve these problems?
These are two problems,
linear systems and
top singular vectors.
They're sort of actually very
closely tied together how
we solve these problems.
They're sort of
the textbook direct methods,
like things you
would learn about
like Gaussian elimination,
or it's Cholesky decomposition.
There's a lot of
work in this area.
These things take a long time.
For an end-by-end matrix,
they take n cubed time.
You can't run these things
on large matrices.
They are really important
algorithms because you often
run them as sort of subroutines
and smaller matrix.
All of my algorithms
will use these sort
of direct methods of
subroutines but will run them
on small samples of
our original matrix.
But you can't just go and
run them on a large matrix,
it's just not possible.
Iterative methods are things
like conjugate gradient
for linear system,
Lanczos methods, gradient
descent for linear systems.
These things, basically,
their basic operation
is doing a matrix
vector multiply,
and they use some
iterative approach to
try to get closer
to the solution to
linear system or solution to
some eigenvectors
with each iteration
being a matrix vector multiply.
These things are generally much
more efficient than
direct methods.
You can actually run
them on large matrices.
You can distribute your matrix
vector multiplies, but again,
every multiplication that you
perform is doing
a full pass over your data.
So, there's still something,
there's still a question of,
is this really the best we can.
Do or do we really need
to make a full pass
over the data for
every single iteration.
And so my work sort of
falls in a third category
of algorithms which is
only sort of recently come
to- recently grown
up in some way.
The methods here are randomized.
So, things like
compressing your matrix
with random hashing
or random projection,
stochastic gradients, what I
mentioned in random sampling,
which I'm going to talk
about in this talk.
These things are trying
to sort of access
your matrix in
a very local or limited way,
not to a full pass over
your matrix for every iteration,
and they're trying
to exploit this to
get faster run times.
You can often get really fast,
surprisingly fast run times,
like one thing you see
sometimes quoted is you can get
run times of the form NNZA,
so that's the number of
nonzeros in your matrix.
So if I stored my matrix
as a sparse matrix,
this would be the time it
takes me to read my matrix,
just the list of entries.
Plus, some lower order terms,
like depending on
lower dimensional terms.
So for low rank
approximation, for example,
you can get run times of
the form order NNZA basically,
order one reads of my matrix,
plus some term which
depends polynomial on d,
the dimension and k, the rank
of the approximation
that you're doing.
And so these can be
a lot faster than
iterative methods which require
many applications and
major approximation,
many things that cost NNZA
if you're doing
sparse matrix multiplication.
And as I said,
they typically
access the matrix in
a very limited or local way.
So, that's what I'm
talking about today,
and specifically I'm
going talk about sort of
the simplest way
you could imagine
to speed up matrix computations,
which is random sub sampling.
You give me some large matrix,
I can't afford to run
a direct method on it.
an iterative method on it.
What I'm going to
do is I'm just going
to subsample it down.
I'm going to select, uniformly,
some subset of the rows which
correspond to data points,
or I'll select some set
of the features,
and I hope for the best. Yeah?
>> Just out of curiosity, so
this iterative methods
which requires
times the number of
iterations like you
said so in typical applications
for like typical,
I don't know, problems,
what should I think T to be?
Is it like hundreds or?
>> It sort of depends.
It should be like thee,
but it's probably dozens or
maybe hundreds. I mean
it sort of depends.
People use these
methods on problems
that they can solve
with these methods.
So, in the case that you
can actually solve
the problem well,
it's maybe dozens or
something like that.
Like on a reasonably
well conditioned matrix.
>> [inaudible].
>> Yeah, it sort of
depends,I guess what the
constant factors on
the NNZ bound are.
I mean, iterative methods,
Yeah, I don't mean
to trash them.
They're still like
a very active area
of research, and they're,
like I think that there's are
a lot of work on
iterative methods in
the numerical computation.
A community that
could be used in data.
>> Usually, people use-
>> Yeah, they use these things.
Yeah. So.
>> Can it depend on
the accuracy you want or?
>> Yeah, usually- so the number
of iterations depends
on the accuracy though.
Usually though
the iterative methods
are much more accurate in,
some sense, than
these randomized methods.
So usually, if you
make some assumptions,
you can get like
a linear convergence, whereas,
these randomized methods,
usually, you're paying.
You're taking samples, and you
get some sort of like
worse convergence.
You need take more samples
to get higher accuracy.
Yeah. These things also
play really nicely together.
So, this is one reason, I mean,
you can often use
randomized methods
to accelerate iterative methods.
Like randomized preconditioning.
You can combine stochastic
gradient methods with them,
so they play nicely
together. All right.
>> Yes. So random subsampling.
This is what I do, if I
don't know what to do,
I could just subsampling
my matrix down,
and then I could
hope that working on
the subsample matrix
seems to work well.
This is used all the time.
So, if you have,
this is used
all the time for example
an exploratory data analysis,
I want to test out
if a model works,
I just subsample
my data points I run
it on a much
smaller set of them,
and just see what happens.
It's also used with
feature sampling.
So for example, in genome X,
they have more intelligent ways
of selecting
features but there's
always some massive feature
selection process first,
there are often some massive
feature selection process
first before any real analysis,
any further analysis happens.
So this is a really
prevalent method.
The problem is
that if you're just
doing uniform sampling,
this is really
cheap but it's also
wasteful in a way
as you can see,
you're just throwing out thing,
you're throwing out information.
You're throwing out data points,
you're throwing out features.
And often the sample doesn't
well represent your matrix.
So, a simple way to see this,
is if I have a cluster dataset C
with some imbalance
in my clusters.
I might not know these clusters
but sort of they fall into,
my data falls into
these three clusters,
and one of them is a lot
bigger than the other ones.
Then if I do uniform sampling,
I'm going to tend to get
more points in that cluster,
and I can easily miss
like all the points
in this third cluster.
And for all I know,
those are the points
that really matter.
Maybe those are
the features that
really contain
a lot of my noise.
So uniform sampling
can be problematic.
And for this reasons, there's
tons of work on figuring
out well what should we do
instead of uniform sampling?
There's sort of clustering,
and distance based
methods, if you've
heard of them,
there are these things
called the terminal point
processes which are a really
nice way of formalizing,
selecting sort of diverse sets
of points or features,
there's classification
based methods
where you sort of run
classification
using small subsets
of the features, and use this.
So there's lots of things
have been studied here.
For example with this problem,
the solution really
when in this case as usual
want to be super hard,
I could cluster my data first,
I could explicitly identify
these clusters, and then,
I could re-balance
my sampling to
try to get enough points
in this cluster.
So, this would sort of overcome
the issue with uniform sampling.
So, these non-uniform
sampling approaches,
these sort of important
often work really well
in practice but the issue
is that there it's
really hard to define
exactly what makes
a good sampling scheme.
We can run a sampling scheme,
we can see what we get as far
as classification accuracy,
or some downstream thing,
and we can declare that
it's good for that problem,
but it makes it really a
hard to develop sort of
generic methods like I
was saying at the
beginning of this talk,
that are based on sampling.
That makes it difficult
to understand,
well how can we get
this to work for
many problems at once?
And how can we prove
that this is the case?
So, in a sense they're sort
of inherently heuristic,
or ad hoc because we don't have,
before we have a good definition
of what a good sampling is.
Okay. So that's sort of
the goal of my work on sampling,
which is basically
to understand what is
the right way to
select data points,
or features for generic
linear algebraic computation
to do fast approximately
algebraic computation.
This is obviously
an interesting question for
all sorts of algorithms and
learning, in optimization.
I'm focusing specifically
here on linear and algebra.
I want some generic
sampling method
that lets me speed
up like solving
linear systems linear
approximation and a lot of
the standards of
those computational tools.
So the first step is that
in designing such a
sampling scheme is
we're going to restrict the
types of schemes we consider.
Specifically, we're going
only look at schemes
which are relatively
simple random processes.
I'm only going to
look at sampling
schemes that look like this.
I assign some sort of score,
some probability between zero
and one for every row
in my matrix.
This represents
the sort of importance
of that point in
composing my matrix,
or my dataset, which I'll
explain how we
compute these later.
And then what I do
is for every point,
I just sample independently
at random with probability Pi.
And so it means
that one time have
this important sampling
distribution set,
my sampling process
is super easy.
It's just flipping
a bunch of biased coins,
in this case is
my sample from my matrix.
And then, I'm going to
hope that this sample
somehow well represents
my original data in some metric.
And we're going to analyze
the effects of the sampling.
I'm not going to get into
this at all during this talk,
but we're going
to analyze this as
a random process, we'll review,
selecting these points
as basically
choosing a random
sampling matrix,
and applying it to
our matrix where just
selects out individual rows
of the matrix.
This is like not, it's not
a huge technical innovation
or anything like this,
but doing random sampling
makes analysis way
easier than for example,
we could have computed
all the scores,
and then just selected
the points with
the highest scores,
or something like this, but
these things become really
difficult to analyze.
Here, we just have
a really simple
independent sampling process and
that's how we're going to try
to approximate our matrix.
So then the question
becomes how do we
compute these probabilities Pi?
So, naturally you think,
well it depends on the problem
I'm trying to solve.
So, for linear systems,
I'm trying to solve this problem
minimize Ax minus b.
What I might want is that
after I sample my matrix,
so I instead to solve the
problem on- it's not working.
I instead solve
the problem on SA,
the sampled version of matrix,
and Sb, the sampled version
of the output vector.
I might want this to give me
a reasonably good solution.
Maybe, it's a near minimum
for my original problem.
So this is I would try
to look for sampling
probabilities,
I guarantee that
this is going to
happen with good probability.
For low-rank approximation,
I might ask a different thing,
I want to sample my matrix,
so I have this matrix essay,
my sample matrix,
I want- it's going to be much
smaller than my original matrix,
I want to compute
its top singular vectors,
and then I want to
project onto them,
compute this AV,
AVs, Vs transpose.
This is a low rank
matrix, if I sent.
If Vs has k columns
this is a k rank matrix.
I want this to be a near
optimal low-rank approximation
if I look at
all ranking matrices,
this one is nearly as close as
possible to my original matrix.
So there's a sort of
optimization viewpoint of
how can I solve this problem
approximately well.
The problem is, is
that, if we start going
through all these
various problems,
it seems like we're
going to require
a different sampling
distributions in
a sort of different analysis for
every single problem that
we're trying to solve.
And this isn't
what I want. I want
something that is very general,
just like you can do
very general analysis
of things like
stochastic already set.
I want something
that applies to a
huge range of problems at once.
So you can just take
the same problem,
the same algorithm, and apply it
to a bunch of
different problems.
And the key idea here is
also pretty simple but it's
pretty powerful is
that instead of looking
at problem specific guarantees,
or I want to approximate
this problem like
nearly optimally,
we're going to look at
really simple spectral
approximation guarantees.
What this means is I'm going
to ask for any vector x,
I'm going to want to preserve
the product with my matrix.
the product A times x.
So, specifically, if I
look at the product
with my sample matrix,
I want this norm to be
close to the norm of
the product with
the original matrix.
And I'm going to allow
myself two types of error.
And I have this Epsilon
multiplicative error,
so it's close multiplicatively.
And then, I also I'm
going to allow myself
some additive error in terms of
this Lambda parameter
which says,
even if for example, Ax
with zero, I'm going to pay,
I'm going to have still
maybe I might not get
exactly zero out when
I multiply by SAx.
This is like a really simple
linear algebraic guarantee.
It's just saying how close A and
SA are when they act
as linear operators.
So basically, say I'm applying
these matrices to vectors,
and I want to make
sure that they're
doing pretty similar things.
And the nice thing is that
this sort of guarantee,
it's easy to write down,
and you can then start
playing around with
this guarantee,
and you can show
that it can be used
if SA satisfies this guarantee.
For example, if it satisfies
this guarantee with
Lambda equals zero,
you can use it to get Epsilon
approximately linear
system solvers,
where precondition is for
linear is for
intuitive system methods.
If you increase Lambda
to the appropriate value,
you can use this to get near
optimal linear
approximation algorithms.
You can use it to get
approximation algorithms
for constrained optimization.
Things like non-negative PCA,
and commune's clustering.
And this has been a lot of- it's
sort of a simple- it
seems simple, right?
Map this guaranteed to
all of these problems,
it's not necessarily
that simple in your off,
it's not necessarily always
as simple as it looks,
and a lot of my work
has been focusing
on what's the right way
to map this guaranteed,
the giving approximation bounds
for all of these problems.
>> If you- this seems to be
a harder condition that's I mean
those specifically
problems, right?
>> Yeah.
>> The algorithm is
more generic but.
>> Yeah. It does
seem to be a harder condition
but sort of in the end,
for example for linear systems.
Yeah. In the end, it seems to
turn out that
the results we can get
match what people
were getting if they
just targeted
those specific guarantees.
And we often get guarantees
that it would be certain.
>> But I would imagine
for the two problems
you mentioned this
seems to be there.
>> Oh, yeah. That's true.
This isn't, yeah, there
are certain problems
where this is definitely
not necessary.
For the two problems
I mentioned,
this is almost like tight in
a way like you better
be getting this.
>> This is a operation?
>> Yeah.
Well because this is
sort of preserving
the spectrum of your matrix.
But yeah, you're right.
For some problems you might,
this might be overkill. Yeah.
>> I guess, I'm kind of
surprised is what you want
us to preserve the norms,
I would've thought
it'd be something
like the difference between
the two projections
instead of that you want
their norms to be
similar like that seems.
>> Yes. So if you just
preserve the di- you mean
the difference between the two
subspaces spanned by these?
>> Like the- some general
like SAx minus Ax,
and then something
about like that being
not too large an average
or something.
>> Yeah, I mean, it's
a little bit hard.
So SAx and Ax are like
different sides of things,
so you have to have
like a certain way
of defining this but
for example this means
like I preserve
distances between if
I'm looking at Ax minus Ay,
this is going to be
approximated by SAx minus SAy.
>> The normal b thus,
approximate norm properly,
not the actual like direction.
>> The norm. And not the
actual direction. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> But generally, yeah.
It won't approximate
the actual direction.
It's a little hard
to see what it
means to approximate the direct.
Yes. Sort of depends. I mean.
SAx and Ax live in
different spaces so
it can be a little,
it's a little hard
to define that. Yeah.
>> Yes.
>> Yeah. Okay.
>> Is also the worst case
for every vector.
>> This is also for
every vector which is
certainly not necessary.
Often this is what we want,
but this is not
necessary all the time.
And for example, like
Johnson Lindenstrauss
said results are doing
us not for every vector,
and they can often do
something much more efficient.
They only care about say,
if we have a bunch of vectors,
I'm trying to compute
closest distances,
I only care about
preserving this for
all those vectors on my dataset,
not for every possible vector.
>> So intuitively,
if you have a data point
repeated like 10
times this presumes it's going
to drop nine of these
occurrences, keep only one.
>> Right.
>> So can you explain
why this does that?
>> So if I literally
have 10 exact repeats
of my data points and if I
knew that I had 10 exact repeats
it's going to drop all but one.
And also S is going to be,
I guess I didn't
mention this but S
is also going to
reweight data points.
It reweights by the inverse
of the probability
I selected them.
So if I literally
exactly knew I selected
them with a probability
of one tenth it will
reweight them up by
one over that probability
by a 10 factor.
So actually what I'll do is I'll
exactly preserve the norm.
I'll basically
compress those all to
one row of my matrix.
So this is when it works
really well but yeah.
And if I have a bunch
of for example
really small data say,
a bunch of data points that,
or I don't know if we should
be thinking about this.
It's hard to just
call them data.
Say I have a bunch of rows in
my matrix that are really small,
they have very small norm.
They will tend to
very small dot products like
my vectors X and those might for
example just be
dropped altogether in
that case might go into
this additive error
term, this lambda.
Okay, any other
questions on this? Yes.
>> So matrix like
S that responds to
semnic points it dependent on
the community pi because
they are very special,
it's like what is it?
Is it like one nonzero per
column or something like?
>> Yeah, they're actually, yeah
they have like one nonzero
per column. Yeah and that's it.
But yeah, what I sort of like
to think about S as, okay,
computationally what it
really is is it's a matrix,
it's an identity matrix
when you just deleted
almost all the columns and
so therefore you're
only selecting like
some subset of that. Yeah.
>> And you could do this
on both ends, right?
You could be doing it on the
feature space as well instead?
>> Yeah. Actually like for
low rank approximation
is actually what
you're more typically doing.
I was just throwing it on.
Yeah, it doesn't matter where
the directions are
going all over bounds,
they'll be for
either sampling data points
or for sampling features.
Yeah. Sometimes it's
more interpretable
for sampling features
in my opinion actually.
Okay? All right. So okay,
we have this bound this is
the bound that we're going
to target it's this very
simple spectral bound.
This bound has been studied in
a lot of different contexts,
and it's sort of
known how to derive
good sampling probabilities in
order to obtain this bound
with good probability.
So there has been some work
in Matrix approximation
literature,
also in spectrograph theory,
algebraic graph theory trying
to get these sorts of bounds.
Not necessarily all of
these works you have
actually slightly
different formulations,
but what I'm going to
show you right now is
like the sort of
cleanness formulation that
we've come up with which
is this thing called The
Ridge leverage score.
This is what I'm
going to find my
sampling probability to be.
The actual form of this
doesn't matter too much,
the point is it's
some score it's
the probability
that I'm going to
sample the higher row
of my matrix.
It depends on that row,
it depends on the matrix and
also depends on this lambda,
this additive error that
I'm going to allow myself.
It's basically
a quadratic form over
the inverse of the Matrix
regularized by that lambda.
The important properties
of this is one
that it can be the sum
of these scores
can be bounded as a function of
lambda and as a function
of the Matrix A.
Which is important because
the sum of the scores,
remember I'm sampling each row
independently with these scores,
so sum of the scores is
my expected sample size.
So if I'm on a FAST
algorithm I'm going to
need some way to bound
some of these scores.
The larger lambda is the
smaller the sum becomes.
When lambda is zero, this is
for example when I need to
do preconditioning or
approximate system solves,
the sum of the scores is
at most the rank of my matrix.
So as long as I
select the number of rows
equal to the rate of my matrix,
I get this thing with additive
error lambda equals zero.
For low rank
approximation you can
do things that are
a lot stronger.
If you appropriately set
lambda and I won't go
into the details here,
you can show that the sum
of these scores is
less than like
for example two K,
where you're looking for
a rank K approximation.
This means that when I
sample from my matrix,
in expectation I get 2K rows.
Meaning I get something like
usually order K rows I
have this small matrix.
I can perform an SVD on
this matrix which is
reasonably inexpensive.
It cost me maybe like
D times K square times.
This is a lot faster
than doing an SVD
in the original Matrix and I
can get near optimal low rank
approximation of
my original Matrix.
So it's critical that
we're able to bound,
we have good bounds
on the sum of
these scores because that's
going to be our sample size.
>> How is this
related to clustering
make sure it's okay means
because a lot of
this maths looks like
you're clustering the rows.
>> Yeah. So if you have
cluster structure in your data,
it will sort of appear
also in these leverage
scores naturally.
What you'll tend to have
is that the leverage,
say the points are
really well clustered.
Then the leverage score
of a row will be
roughly like one over
the size of the cluster
that it's in.
If they're really well
clustered and then it's
sort of a continuous insert,
it will continuously interpolate
as the data becomes
less well clustered.
Yeah. So this is one nice thing
is this isn't so far from.
It's also really
close related to
DPP like determinants
of point processes.
The marginal
distributions of DPP for
example are like the properly
defined levered score.
So, it's not so far what
people do in practice,
but it's sort of a cleaner,
it can give you some cleaner
guarantees when you sample.
Okay. Yes.
>> For low rank
approximation is there
any way to make
it K times low for
that row instead of like
a constant clustering?
>> Yeah. No, not really.
So it depends sort
of what you're loo-
if you're looking for,
here I'm hiding
epsilon factors really.
Say I'm looking for
a constant factor
in Optimal low
rank approximation,
if I want to get say something
within 0.1 of the optimal,
you can prove that
I better select,
I need to at least look at like
10 times K rows of my matrix.
>> What if like the budget
is only an epsilon percent of
K like if that's the number
of rows I can select
anyway to get one laps of
approximation or something?
>> Yeah. I'm not really sure.
I don't know whether
you can do that.
Definitely there's a way
to run these algorithms,
I'll talk later about
kernel approximation where I
give a budget on how much I
want to sample and
I sample under that.
But typically the type of
guarantees you get is I
give you a sample of you
can only sample K rows,
you better only sample K rows,
but then you maybe get
an approximation bound
which is matching the best K
over two approximation.
Right, K over two.
Yeah, things like that.
You have like trade
off there. All right.
Okay, so what have we
accomplished so far?
We basically tried to take
these problems
that we care about,
these linear system solving
low rank approximation and
write them as
a simple guarantee.
And this is let us get a really
nice sampling distribution
this leverage
for distribution that
we can prove gives
good approximation if
we take enough samples.
And we also have an explicit
data dependent formula
for this distribution.
So this is great,
we actually have
the distribution in hand
and we've removed a lot
of the ad hocness from
sampling for these problems.
What's the problem is sort
of if you look at the form
of this thing it's glaring is
that I have to solve
a linear system
just to compute one of
these probabilities,
and I'm trying to accelerate
these sort of methods.
So, solving this linear system
has generally been pretty much
as hard as the
original problem I'm
trying to solve and we
need to get around this.
And this is a major
contribution or work.
What we basically show
is that we can officially
bootstrap these leveraged scores
from uniform sampling.
So I sort of knocked on
uniform sampling earlier,
I said it often cannot
represent your matrix very well,
but we can actually
use it really
powerfully for approximating
leverage scores.
Specifically what I can
do is, I have my matrix.
I want to compute
leverage score so that
I can sample
my matrix accurately.
What I do is I
first uniform sample
half the rows of the Matrix,
and then I'm going
to approximate
leverage scores in
this really simple way.
If my row is in my sample,
so if my row AI is in
the sample of one half this
will happen half the time,
then I'm just going to
compute the leverage score
in the smaller matrix A bar.
If my row is not in my matrix,
what I'm going to
do is I'm gonna
append it to the smaller matrix,
I'm going to sort of
pretend that I sampled
it and I'm going to impute
the leverage score
in this larger matrix
A bar with a row appended.
So I'm just going to
approximate the leverage
scores by cutting my matrix in
half and then
basically computing
leverage scores in
the smaller matrix,
and hope that
these things actually will
approximate my original scores.
And this is what we're
going to show. We're going
to show that overall
these approximate
leverage scores are
good approximations of
the true leverage scores. Yeah.
>> Good enough that you can
articulate this problem.
>> Yes this will be
the next slide. Actually yeah.
>> Wait, so is it some kind
of thing you can
do if you shouldn't
you can recompute it
for all your rank?
>> This thing?
>> Yeah.
>> In the end, what I'll show
you but it's going to
be a rank one update.
First of all. Yeah it will be
a rank one update to
the universe so you can
do that efficiently.
Actually what you can do
is something even simpler
where you just compute
the leverage score in
this matrix and you use
the minimum of
that leverage score
in one, the probability of one.
So you can actually use
an even simpler outcome.
You don't need to
actually compute this out.
Yeah. Okay, so why
is this enough?
So, because you can
iterate this process.
So I want to compute
the leverage scores
in this matrix A bar.
This requires computing
some linear system,
computing some quadratic form
over the inverse of
A bar which is half the size
of my original matrix but
it's still pretty big,
plus maybe a rank
one perturbation which I
could deal with efficiently
in a number of ways.
But the problem is
A bar is still too big.
So what I'm going to
do is I'm just going to
recursively approximate A bar
using leverage score sampling.
Okay, so what does
that look like?
I start with my original matrix,
I cut it in half
to get A bar one.
I call that my
first uniform sample.
This is still too
big to work with so I
cut in half again
to get A bar two.
I keep cutting in half until I
finally get to a matrix that
I can actually work with.
Note that this is just a uniform
sample of my matrix and I can
maybe I stop when I
can find the memory I
stop when there's
one row, whatever.
And then what I do is say
I went down to two levels.
I use A bar two to
approximate the leverage
works for A bar one.
A bar two is just a uniform
sample of A bar one,
but my claim on
the previous side I can do
a good job approximating
its leverage score.
I can then sample from A bar one
to get a good
approximation to A bar one,
and then what I can show is that
this approximation
can be used to
approximate the leverage
score of A itself.
A bar one could be used
to approximate
these leverage score.
It's not very hard to show that
A tilda one can also approximate
these leverage scores.
And so finally I work
my way up to the top of
the computation and I compute
the leverage scores
reasonably accurately.
Okay? So that's
the entire algorithm.
The key is just proving
that uniform sampling,
if I uniform sample in half
this computes leverage score.
That's all we need to prove
to get this thing to work.
Okay. This is what
we need to show.
We need to show that
our approximate
leverage scores which
we got from uniform sampling
are good approximations.
To do this, we actually need
two really natural properties
of the leverage scores.
One, we knew that they are
bounded by something so,
for linear systems,
in that case,
they're bounded by
the rank of the matrix.
When you appropriately set
lambda for a low-rank
approximation,
they're bounded by some
universal upper down 2k,
where k is the rank of the
approximation you care about.
It's natural they're
bounded. They better be
bounded because we're
sampling by them.
If they're not bounded,
then we don't know how big
our sample size is going to be.
We use that they're bounded,
and that they're monotonic,
which just means that if I
remove rows from my matrix,
the leverage scores of
the remaining rows only go up.
And this is a very
natural property
for an important
sampling metric.
A row can only get more
important as other rows leave.
Okay. How can we use these to
prove that these approximate
leverage score are good?
The first claim is that
my approximate leverage
scores are only
larger than my true
leverage scores.
This means I'm only going
to sample every row.
In my final process, I'm
going to sample every row with
some slightly higher probability
than I should've
but this is fine.
I'm only going to do
a better approximation
if I sample more rows.
How do I get this? Well, this
follows immediately
about monotonicity.
In the first case, I'm just
computing the leverage score
against a bar.
That contains half
the rows of my matrix.
The leverage scores
of the remaining rows
have only increased over
their original value so
I approximate over
approximate in that case.
Same within the second case,
I'm looking at
"a bar union AI".
This is still
a subset of my matrix.
The importance of
AI in this subset is
only more important than it's
importance in the whole matrix.
I have that I have over
approximation stat
leverage scores.
Then what I need to show is that
the expected sum of
the leverage scores.
Remember that the
some of the true
leverage scores was
something like 2k,
I need to show
the expected sum of
these approximate
leverage scores
aren't that much larger,
so my sample size is
roughly the same size.
So they over approximate
my sampling probabilities,
but not by so much and this
is all I need to get
a fast algorithm.
I'm not going to show
you the proof of this but
it's really easy to prove.
This is what it gives you.
You basically use
an averaging argument.
You show that the
average leverage score in
"a bar union AI"
is not too large,
and then you sum up
these expectations,
and you show that
this expectations are too large.
That's actually super
easy to prove this.
You only need
the monotonicity property
and this boundedness property.
Actually, I don't think you
need the monotonicity property
for that one.
Okay. That's it.
What's the upshot?
We show that uniform
sampling can be-
We define some nice
importance measure,
and we show that it can
be well approximated
with uniform sampling. Yeah.
>> Including this "big O"
so when you iterate that,
so you don't have the
uniform constant that's
valid for all the
iterations or you do?
I'm wondering what
because you're going to go
from any of the two variables
or four and so on,
and this "big O"
uniform and all these
iterations or this is just
for the first iteration.
>> It is uniform. Also, there's
a little details
I'm hiding under
the rug which is you
need to set lambda.
Say we're doing linear systems
and lambda was zero,
this would be this value k
would be rank of the matrix
if lambda was zero,
and always this
would be bounded by
something like four times
the rank of the matrix,
something like uniform for
every single iteration.
If the rank of
your matrix happens
to go down when you sample,
then it might get a little
bit better but it's never going
to be worse than the rank
of the original matrix.
In low-rank
approximation setting,
it's bounded by
some constant times
the service stable rank
of the initial matrix.
This thing is going
to only again go
down as you sample so it is
really bounded by some uniform.
I mean, it is bounded by
better and better things
as you go down,
but in worst case by the top.
>> You said these
are increasing,
so how could it go down?
>> The leverage scores
are increasing
but you're removing
rows so the sum of
the leverage score is
actually only going
down or staying the same,
I mean yeah, off, yeah.
This is the fast.
Okay. Here, the upshot is we use
uniform sampling to approximate
these leverage scores,
these leverage scores give
approximation for
a lot of problems.
It gives us a fast,
generic importance
sampling algorithm
for a lot of linear
algebraic problems.
>> What is the quality
of the approximation?
What is the difference
between lambda and
lambda and another one?
>> You can actually bound.
You can't actually say
that lambda theta, for example,
is a constant factor of- Oh,
you can't actually say that
tau theta is within
a constant factor of
tau for every single i.
In some cases, for example,
like tau i might be zero,
and tau theta might be
some positive numbers.
You can't bound them
so you just have
that in aggregate/ you have
a constant factor
approximation so the sum of
the approximated ones are
only a constant factor
higher than
the sum of the real ones
and you use this
as a sampling probability
so it means you take
a constant factor
of a larger sample.
It's sort of you pay it as
a runtime cost the difference.
>> If instance,
what I'm always asking
is they would actually
do constant to the same equation
so by sampling once you're
losing the constant so
usually use that with
sampling 2k and then you
lost constant factor,
why this constant why this
constant doesn't navigate or-
>> Well, I only care
about this for one level
so I sample once but I
don't really care about,
I don't care, I'm
going to ignore
the leverage versus
top level for now.
I just want to approximate
the leverage scores
of the second level.
So yeah you don't you don't pay.
You're not trying to
approximate the leverage
scores of the top level with,
for example, the third level.
You only you first sample
this you first sample
a_1 and you get
some approximation
to it so you get like
a constant factor spectrum
approximation, the 10 factor.
Then what the constant is
going to blow up by from going
from a_1 to a is something like
10 times two or something,
and then you fix this in
every single iteration so
it doesn't blow up.
Does that make sense?
>> Well, I would need
to think about it.
>> Yeah. Roughly speaking,
things don't balloon
out themselves.
>> It sounds too good to
be true but I'm sure is
>> It's because you can always
pay for- if you have enough
if you have approximate scores,
you can always sort
of correct for this by
just oversampling
by a constant factor
and now you have just as good
of approximation as
you would have gotten.
It's as if the rest
of the recursion
didn't matter at all.
Now, you just look at
one level and you complete
that level and you keep going.
Okay. The upshot is
these fast generic important
sampling algorithms.
You can get nice
asymptotic run times,
you can get things that
basically match linear
sketching methods or
stochastic gradient where you're
paying for sort of like order of
one times the number of
non zeros in your matrix
plus some smaller term like
this dk square term for
a low rank approximation.
It's really easy to
adapt them to streaming
online and distributed
settings because it's
not you can sort of easily
sort of distribute
your computation of
these leverage scores
and then merge them back
together at the end.
More importantly than
these exact run times
is that you can
apply this methods in
contexts where
previous approaches like
traditional iterative methods or
random sketching
completely fail.
I'm going to give you
an example of that
for kernel methods.
In kernel methods
basically I am trying
to learn some non-linear
relationship amongst my data.
I do this by replacing
my standard inner product with
some nonlinear inner product.
This kernel function "KXIXJ".
Maybe it's like
the Gaussian kernel,
which I showed up there.
In this simplicity defines
this end by end
kernel matrix where
every entry is the inner product
between data point "X" and data,
or data point "I"
and data point "J".
Now even writing
down this kernel
matrix takes "N" squared time.
I might not want
to explicitly write
it down but even doing like in
a single iteration of
a linear system solver on
this kernel matrix
I am trying to
solve regression in
this kernal matrix.
This takes "N"
squared time we're
applying a single round
of random projection,
or hashing, this also
takes "N" squared time.
So this is really expensive.
Even if "N" is 200,000
if it's not even that
big of a dataset,
I have 40 billion
entries it will
typically be a dense matrix.
It takes 300 gigabytes to store
this thing just becomes
very on unwieldy
especially if I go up
to like millions of
data points and suddenly this
is just not possible to run,
to work with this kernel matrix.
Basically, all implementations
of kernel methods
at large scale use
low rank approximation.
You always take your kernel
and you approximate it by
some product ZZ transpose
where it has some limited
number of columns.
You can store this
in a lot less space.
You can do
computation a lot more
efficiently you
basically need to do
this and you get some sort of
linear and end runtime,
which is important.
And there's a lot of methods for
computing kernel approximations
and linear times.
Things based on incomplete
Cholesky Factorization.
This nice strong method
is especially popular.
There's this
well-known technique
called random for
feature sampling,
which can be viewed as giving
a low rank approximation of
your mission of your matrix.
All these things run in
roughly linear in end time.
That means that
they're, for example,
not computing every entry of
the kernel matrix
and they have to pay
for this in the end they
never give error
that's comparable.
Ideally, I don't
want the best ranked
S approximation of
my kernel matrix.
Computing this would
be super expensive.
If I wanted to do it even using
an iterative method
even if my iterative
method completed
in one iteration
it would take n squared time.
So these things are
doing something much
more limited to that
and they're never
getting approximation
in terms of
the best rank S approximation.
What we can show with
ridge leverage for
sampling is we can
actually close this gap
sort of surprisingly.
We show that you
can actually get
a linear time method that gives
a near optimal low rank
approximation in sort of
the sense that you
want, which is this.
We start with this
basic thing called nice-
>> What does linear time-
I mean linear looks?
>> Sorry. By linear time, I mean
linear in n and it will be-
>> N times the original input
of these vectors that
you used to compute.
>> Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. I'll explain
what exactly I mean, yeah.
So the n times the size of
your original input, yeah.
We're sort of like
n- yeah, yeah.
Yes. So, we got
a method that does this.
Actually, I'm running low
on time so I'm going to skip
the exact basis of
the method but let
me just tell you what
the result is. Actually, no.
Fine, I'll explain. So, we
base it off this thing
called Nystrom Approximation,
which is basically
like you sample
some landmark data points
from your data set and
you form some approximation
based off the sample.
You can view this as basically
sampling some points
in kernel space.
So, a big way
that you work with
kernel methods is that you
write the kernel
as an inner product
between vectors and
some higher dimensional space.
Some moves in infinite
dimensional space,
so I'm being really
informal here.
But think about these as
high-dimensional vectors.
I sample points in this space
and I project the rest
of my points to them
and that's how I
approximate my kernel matrix.
What we can show is that,
if you sample
these landmark points with
their ridge leverage scores
in kernel space,
in your sample something like
s over epsilon landmarks.
Then, you can get
an approximation
not of the kernel matrix K,
but of this kernel data
set where every row is
one of your kernelized
data points.
You can get a near
optimal approximation.
So, basically, the approximation
produced by Nystrom is
within one plus epsilon of
the optimal low-rank
approximation of this matrix.
And your run time is linear in n
and quadratic in s
or it's linear in n
and the number of
kernel evaluations you have to
compute and then
the additional computation you
need is linear in
n and quadratic in
s. And it doesn't compute
the entire kernel matrix
at K. We also get balance for
a bunch of other problems,
basically, by going through
the spectral guarantees.
And this closes a big gap
between linear time methods
which are basically,
the only thing you can run in
practice and actually getting
some sort of nice near
optimal approximation amount.
And practically speaking,
it works really well.
So, I've plotted run times here.
The important part is
that where this blue line.
We compare to these other
linear time methods
that don't give like
a near optimal approximation
to the kernel and we're
way faster than quadratic time
which essentially
just doesn't scale.
And then our approximation error
is somewhere in
between these methods,
but it's going down much faster.
A lot of the time,
these other methods sort of
stagnate once you get to
a certain number of samples.
Ours is actually
going down much,
much faster and much
closer to what you'd
get with this slow
method which is,
in this case, is
random projection.
>> So, your algorithm
was black line, right?
>> No, our algorithm
is blue line.
Black line is like if you
took your kernel
matrix and applied
a random projection which
actually is really
expensive because you
have to compute
the kernel matrix.
We don't do as well as that,
but we do much better
than the other ones.
>> [inaudible]
sounds a little bit.
>> Yes, well, the thing
is that I can't compute.
It's hard to compute
these approximation errors.
It requires computing
the spectrum
of a super large matrix.
So, the reason this is small is
because it's actually
pretty small.
These matrices are
not very large.
It's just disclosed
to show scaling.
Okay. I guess I'm a
little low on time.
I'll briefly summarize
an even more surprising result
you can get which
comes out of
these kernel methods
which is that I
give you any PSD,
and this is again
using the ridge
leverage for
sampling techniques.
I give you any PSD matrix,
I can output a near optimal
low-rank approximation and
the run time is
something like NK
squared over some Pi
and over epsilon.
Note that my matrix,
I have no assumptions
on this matrix.
So, it could be dense,
it could have N squared entries,
it could have
terrible condition number,
it could be very incoherent,
yet I don't need to read
this matrix and I can
still get in a near optimal
rank approximation to it.
And this is just
by bootstrapping
this sort of kernel algorithm.
We factor the PSD matrix as
its square root times itself.
If we applied the kernel
approximation algorithm,
you can work through
our bounds and
you'd see that we'd approximate
the square root of
this matrix which isn't the
same as approximating
the matrix itself,
but we show is that you
can do something better.
You can basically
sample rows and
columns of the matrix by
the leverage squares
of the square root.
You can do it officially and you
can get down to this core of
the matrix which contains
very few rows and
columns and from this,
you can extract a near optimal
low-rank approximation.
The details don't really matter,
I thought that this
was surprising.
The only structural property we
exploit from the matrix
is that it's positive
semi-definite and then
we don't need to read
the whole matrix and we can get
a near optimal
low-rank approximation.
>> [inaudible]
>> Yes, so this is like,
first of all this is our bounds.
I don't know if it is
actually the right thing,
but it probably is
at least one over epsilon.
We have a lower bound
of one over epsilon
and probably at least one
over epsilon squared.
But even if for example,
if you apply a constant factor,
often you're seeing your tail of
your matrix fall
off really quickly.
So, you're not looking
for really good epsilon.
You just care about getting most
of the master matrix
and you're paying.
So, I guess, I don't know,
does this end at half past or.
>> Yeah, we had better
quickly wrap up.
>> Yeah. So, why don't I wrap
up on the linear
algebra section.
I can take questions on it
and then if people want to stay,
I can talk about
the BIOS stuff or I
can just skip it, we can decide.
Okay? So, okay,
this is a summary.
What was the right way
to select data points and
features for linear
algebraic computation?
We considered simple,
important sampling strategies.
We defined like a very clear
spectral approximation goal
and this led us to find
very clear probabilities.
We then made this algorithmic
an efficient by
bootstrapping
uniform sampling and
we're getting some
pretty powerful results
for kernel methods and for
PSD matrices and hopefully,
we can get more powerful
results in areas
where other randomized methods
don't really suffice.
In this talk, I mostly talked
about sampling,
one-shot sampling.
I have a big matrix and I
want to approximate it once.
But obviously, you can use
sampling in a lot of other ways.
So, an obvious one is a part of
iterative methods
and understanding
how you can use
sampling, for example,
to speed up
second order methods,
is a really big question in
a sort of alternative way of
using it in linear algebra.
You can use these methods,
these iterative methods, to
give fast algorithms as I
mentioned for lots of
linear algebraic problems.
So, it's really interesting
area to look at.
And also, we've been
interested recently in
generalizing this word beyond
basically in linear
algebraic problem,
for example, sampling
Fourier features.
We've used this specifically
for kernel approximation,
but hopefully can be used in
other Fourier
analysis computation
and sampling for
Fourier techniques.
And maybe for
other types of models.
And the last thing
I'll mention is that
I've been talking
this entire time about
how important randomness is and
approximation in these
algorithms I'm showing you.
We don't really
actually understand it.
I don't know that
this is really true.
So, I'll tell you
one fact which is
that any fast algorithm
on a matrix.
So, basically anything
that runs in faster than
order n cubed time or
faster than fast matrix
multiplication time,
if you want to think about that,
uses one of two techniques.
Either it makes
assumptions on the matrix,
assume something like bounded
condition number or
bounded eigenvalue bounds.
This is how you get
classic iterative methods.
Or it does what we're doing,
it uses randomization.
It pays these one over epsilon
squared or one over epsilon
to the fourth factors.
All algorithms I
know of except for
doing something like computing
the trace or something,
for any non-trivial problem,
they fall into one of
these two paradigms and we
want to explain why this is.
Is there anything
else we can do?
Do we really need to be using
randomization
approximation in order
you get around assumptions?
Or are there some class of
faster algorithms that we just
don't know about yet?
But a really simple
question, just a thought,
it's not even known how to
deterministically
compute an approximation
of the top singular value of
a matrix without computing
eigendecomposition.
Is this really the
best we can do?
Can you prove that it
should be the best we
can do or can or are
we really stuck there?
Okay, so I close on that and
then I can take questions,
general questions.
>> See if you could
do two minutes
of strongest cool pictures
of ants and stuff,
that would be.
>> Yeah, I can do that.
>> Just really quickly. I think
everybody wants us to see it.
>> Okay. I know
any algorithms aren't more
boring than ants for a second.
I'll just tell you exactly
the thing that we've studied.
So, what we've been
interested in is understanding
there's all these
biological systems that
are essentially running
randomized algorithms.
Ants essentially run
randomized algorithms,
and not only do they run them,
we know what they're running.
Because biologists can
probe their behavior,
and figure out how does
this ant make this decision?
What's the input that causes
them to make this run decision?
But, biologists don't
really have a good way of
analyzing to figure out how
all of these things
fit together.
So, the process that we've
been studying is basically,
there's these certain ants,
these rock ants, that basically,
they have to do
this process of when
their nest becomes too small
because their colony grew a lot,
or when their nest is
destroyed for some reason,
they have to go find a new nest.
And they have to do this
in a distributed way.
So, there's no central
controller to say,
"Look for a new nest
and move to it."
So, the algorithm that
they run is first,
some scout agents, some small
subset of the population.
They notice that their nest is
messed up for whatever reason,
and they start going
looking for new nest sites.
They assess these nest sites,
and they can do this,
each individual ant
is complex enough
to actually assess
the quality of a nest site.
They can roughly
measure its size,
they can measure
how much light is in there,
so sort of how protected
it is from the elements
and things like this.
So you get some sort
of really coarse
approximation to its quality.
Both of these things are random.
They're not doing some sort
of grid search or something,
they're just randomly
walking around them,
and when they see
a nest site, they assess
its quality and this
triggers something.
If it's above a certain
threshold, they make a decision.
This decision is that
they decide to recruit
other scouts to try to
assess this nest quality.
So, if the nest is
good enough, they
go back to the home nest.
They randomly walk around,
they randomly bump
into another ant,
and then they try to
recruit it to actually doing
its own independent
assessment of the nest.
It does its own
random assessment.
They keep doing this process,
eventually it builds up to
a sort of quorum
threshold of ants that
actually think this new nest
is like a good nest.
This is also a random process
that's why I have it up.
What they then do, is
they decide on this nest.
So, if there's
enough scouts that
are somehow recruiting
to this nest,
they can actually sense this.
It triggers something
in their mind
where they say this
is our new home,
and then what they
do is they initiate
a decision making process.
What they do is
they actually move
the entire rest of the colony
over to this new nest site.
And this is sort of
necessary because a lot
of the agents in
the colony are on mobile.
So, the queen is in mobile,
the brood is in mobile,
there's a lot of ants
that for whatever reason
aren't understood.
They just sit around
and don't do anything.
What they do is they
literally go back to the nest,
they pick up
the other ants and they
just carry them to
this new nest site.
And this is how they
move. And so this is like
>> They're auditioning.
>> Yeah, exactly.
Or they're trying to
analyze the algorithm.
It's actually a super
well understood algorithm.
Biologists know
exactly what they're doing.
They can test things
like for example,
they can test if they can
prevent the ants from
reaching quorum threshold.
They literally do things like
put skirts around the ants,
little wire skirts so they
can't interact with other ants.
And then they notice
that for example,
they'll never reach
quorum threshold
because they can never
detect when they're bumping
into other ants, and
things like that.
So, they can really
test what they're doing.
The question becomes
analyze what they're doing,
why is it working with
a good probability for them,
and also like why
are they doing it?
How is the quorum
threshold decided?
So, should the quorum
threshold increases
colony size increases,
or should it be independent
of the size of the colony?
Should it have
something to do with
the number of potential
nest sites in the area?
Do they adapt it,
or is it just fixed?
Answering all these
questions is really
interesting questions
for biologists,
and there are questions that
we have the tools to solve.
>> So, how do
you gently evaluate whether
they found a good nest?
>> So, usually it's
in a lab setting,
and there are some parameters
you have to decide
what makes a good nest.
But, usually you set up
a nest in a lab setting
that, for example,
some nest will have a closed top
which is good for them
because it's more protected,
some will have no top at all.
Some will have a small entrance
which is easy to defend,
some will have a large entrance.
So you can sort of, some vague
understanding of
what good means.
>> And what happens if
two quorums forms
about the same time?
>> Yes. This is sort
of the fail case.
I mean, one fail case
is getting a bad nest.
The fail case that happens more
often at least in
lab situations,
but it doesn't
seem to happen for
whatever reason in
nature is, they split.
The queen can only go to
one of those colonies,
so the other colony will
die out unless they move.
Usually, what happens
is they do move.
So, usually what happens
is if the nests
are close enough,
they also have a process
where they notice that
there's two nests,
and then they
eventually recombine.
But it often takes a long time.
There's not a group who are
trying to take the queen ant?
>> Yes. You don't have
like a fight over that,
because I don't think they're
coordinated enough to do that.
But in general,
if you end up in a nest
without the queen,
then that subset of
the population will just,
basically, they'll die off.
I mean not the
individual ants but.
>> So, you mentioned that
they do random exploration.
Is there any good
understanding call,
like what is it
their random number?
Generators? Or they
can use them too?
>> I don't, so no. I mean.
>> Right.
Did you use random in the
precise? So, it's random.
>> I use them in precise.
This is the only way that
I've seen them studied.
Well, as I'm getting
on the next slide,
let me answer that
in one second.
So, we have some work
trying to understand
this quorum-virtual
strategies and when
it's effective, and
why it's useful.
It has close connections,
not surprisingly, with
distributed consensus protocols.
And then we also have
some work on zooming
in on one primitive
that these ants use,
which is estimating
population density.
This is what they use to
test their quorum threshold.
So, if there's
a high density in the nest,
this means that
probably more scouts
are trying to recruit there,
and then they're more
likely to be in quorum,
and it's a good time
to move to that nest.
And so, how do they
estimate population density?
Well, they walk around randomly,
and they count
the number of times that
they bump into another ant.
The more times they
bump into another
ant the higher the density,
the less times
the lower the density.
And what we do is, we
basically analyze this process,
and give some sort
of analysis about
why they're able
to analyze density,
and why this suffices for
something like quorum threshold.
Now, our analysis assumes
that there are literally
random walking agents,
which is certainly not true.
What you can do
to sort of try to
at least test
whether the analysis.
So, what some people have
done, at least to test to
some degree whether the analysis
holds although you would
need to do more work,
is for example, take
videos of these ants,
label them individually, and
count the number of collisions
you have between different ants,
and then look at
the distributions,
the movements of
these distributions,
how many times you
collide with other ants.
And then you can say,
is this about what you'd
expect if they were walking
around in uniform, or random?
So, some people
have actually done
work on this, following
up on our work,
and they do show that it
is close to what you'd
expect from a
uniform distribution.
>> So, zero approximation
of this random assumption is
>> Yes, exactly.
So, at least to some degree
this random
assumption is decent,
and you could potentially
do other things.
So, you can try
to test it like to
some degree. I think
that's it actually.
There's close connections
with social links.
So, estimating
population density
is not so different
from estimating area.
The area that you're
spread out over,
and there's close connections
estimating the size of
social networks via sampling.
So, we show some
connections there.
So, that I'll wrap up and then
take questions in the end.
So, ask one in the general area.
>> Any kind of intervention
during the process?
Like you deliberately
change the potential nest?
Or you deliberately
skirt the ants?
>> Yes. So, this is
the one example I was saying
was with these metal skirts.
What they'll do is
they'll let the ants
run the process mostly,
and then they'll somehow
restrict their movement,
or restrict so that you can
see whether or not
the ant will make it.
They would have made
a decision, and you
stopped them from
making that decision.
>> So you stop them up when
they've already started
investigating the nest,
or at the very beginning?
>> You stop them,
in this experiment
that I'm talking about,
you actually stop them after
they've already investigated and
also recruited some other ants
to that nest and stuff.
I mean, there's
a lot of really cool,
I don't actually design
these experiments.
This is like, we're working
with people that design
these experiments.
But they do a lot
of physical things.
For example, there's
a lot of studying on
how they can cooperatively
transport large pieces of
food which is something
they do a lot.
In there, you can put
four sensors on this fake food,
you can put four sensors,
and you can try to figure out
exactly what they're doing.
>> So, I have a question
on the previous point.
So, you said many of
your algorithms for
sampling, you could
distribute them.
They can also have
the distributed model.
So, what exactly is
the distributed model?
Because, I think that
given that specification
and things,
I don't know whether they can be
solely in distributed settings.
>> I'm just vaguely saying that,
I'm just talking
about a model where I
have a number of servers.
Say, they're well
connected to each other,
and each of them holds
some subset of my data.
It's really natural
to distribute
our algorithm to
these sorts of models,
because you can
compute leverage square
separately on the data sets.
And by this nice monitor nests,
see if properly you
can really easily
merge your samples together.
So, I compute leverage square
separately on the different
subsets of my data.
I sample it down to get
some sort of small subset,
and then I can recombine.
When I recombine
in my laboratories,
I'll only decrease
and then I can
sample them out basically.
So, I'm not talking about
a model for example,
where every single data point
is its own server, or
something like this.
>> Right. I mean,
you worked with Defiance and
they have really specific.
>> Yes, I'm not talking about
those recent models you have.
So, people that
I work with yeah.
>> But, I think that
specification in the
distributed model is quite an.
>> I think this is now known.
There's some recent
progress on this
using some random
spanner type methods.
Either way, it is
important questions.
But I'm not thinking about
those sorts of models currently.
>> I guess, let's take the rest
of the questions offline.
And thank the speaker.